the idea is to like build a space where
people can come together and work on a
project collectively and then also reap
the benefit or like harvest things
collectively fresh local is an
organization that is working on using
urban spaces to grow food we have a
flagship demonstration garden which is
called sigh of a farm where we are now
we came about with systems where we
could do organic farming we've done a
lot of planters where in one square foot
now you can go have like 15 different
plants we're going different types of
things we're going ABB's we're going
vegetables we're going food tree when
we're doing this community farming it's
it's it's like a really good icebreaker
and also another place to go to on
Sundays and Saturdays otherwise right
now it's just the mall
there's a lot more people concerned
about where food is coming from a lot of
people are concerned with health now so
yeah I think that is a ship and plus I
think it's very distressing when you're
just gardening when you're just digging
even if you are just putting whatever
your plans it's very it's a nice thing
Oh